chat after starting oh dirt there are they're almost
starting sorry we're here now we're here it's realized
they're almost starting sorry sorry i was gonna start early
uh i wonder who's team i'm rooting for i don't know i i
wonder who's team i'm on
Oh shit.
Oh, I got signed out of almost every...
Well, I didn't get signed out.
It was mostly Discord.
I got signed out of Discord.
And then I was trying to fix all my Discord settings too.
Because I woke up.
I was like, everything's gonna be alright.
And then everything...
Spoiler.
Everything was not alright.
No.
Everything was not okay.
Alright.
They're doing the countdown.
Where are they playing right now?
now.
I don't even know.
I'm not a doll.
one.
Woo!
Kick off!
Where's my timer?
Boom.
There we go.
We're all in.
Let's go!
Holland!
I just want him just for the memes, honestly.
The reason why I didn't...
He's someone that understands football explaining why
doesn't Holland listen.
He's like...
the smaller players guys thank you the super chat thank you
thank you because I think cannibalism might be is
cannibalism against FIFA rules right on time I think he's
just built for memes honestly he is like the new generations
messy wait how then is I'm
not sure if there's a you're right I don't is a rule against
why doesn't holland just eat them well if if you're gonna if
you're gonna eat well to eat holland uh this this sap wait
that's my manager wait i'm telling you might need a new
manager guys i think i think why don't you like holland what
what's up about Harry Kane!
Oh, yeah, great.
Oh, shit, they're ready.
I forgot that, I don't know why I thought Norway would,
because, like, I guess, like, Norway wore a lot of white
jerseys her away.
So I was like, okay, white is England, red is Norway, as
foretold on their flags.
It's the organization, FIFA, so you can probably bribe
someone to let Canada Slide.
Lonnie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sydney, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Guys, you know what's better than British Meeku?
Norwegian Meeku.
Today, anything's better than British Meeku.
I'm sorry.
Norway versus England match I ordered Jolly Bees so I'm
waiting for Jolly Bees right now at least this is less Haram
ball I'm glad you know what that's that's I'm happy anything
to make me watch less Haram ball what are you doing guys why
are you after I talked about Haram ball why are you guys
passing back and forth See, this is why people cheer for
Holland.
This is exactly why.
It's a battle of attackers.
I didn't say I was live.
Yeah, I should tweet that.
I didn't tweet my waiting room either.
It was a lot of things that I didn't do.
But I was like, I'm like all over the place right now
mentally.
I have to...
Manager!
Manager, I have to re-sign into the manager.
count i lost all my discord logins please dm me your
password okay live right now i did sleep i okay so for those
who didn't know um when i said i was gonna play one more
game after the food break um i might have uh i might have
played morning, just one more game.
Just a maybe.
How many is?
Well, I'm top 200 right now, so that's all that matters.
Please!
Boo!
Holland, eat him!
Holland, you don't say it.
The haram balling!
Eat him!
Well,
wins a win exactly a wins a win can't end on a loss i
actually ended on a win if i wasn't so tired i would have
kept going i think i got pizza to like rank 21.
i was playing with eating pizza last night well i was so i
soloed and then played like a couple of games with eating
pizza and then because he had like if you guys didn't know
in rivals um we're talking about rivals while we're watching
football but in rivals if you're too high rank Queues can go
up to like 20 to one hour plus if you're solo queue.
So if you duo with someone, your queues get shortened to
like 5 to 10 minutes or even less.
So at the moment I duode with pizza, he was in a 30 minute
queue before we duode.
And in the moment we duode, oh my god, Halas, he's right
there.
He's white and you pass to him.
He's white and he's red.
Yeah.
pizza to rank 21 and I got the top 200 you're welcome how
then why did you just eat him so then you could get the ball
you can't say that toky oh hey gully who are you cheering
for see
I'm also red too I'm practically Norwegian I heard Holland
is like an honorary Mexican too.
He was replied to all like the Mexican supporters.
And he's like, don't worry.
I'll beat up England for you.
Yeah, tournament to candy.
Oh, shit.
I think England might be more aggressive though.
No, I feel England definitely has more of a possession.
More possession of the ball.
He has the power of Latin America.
his side what the fuck did he do what
did he do is that off side yeah off side it's always off i
was like what happened it's always and it's just off side
it's always off side if you don't know what's going on yeah
i heard i would know like um they they did an interview with
him and they're like why don't you play for England because
you were born there and then he was just like uh because I
live in Norway for most of my life like oh my god oh he's so
humble he's like I you know what I'll try to let you guys
score I've done too much scoring like
you're like uh it's only natural because I lived I've only
lived in England for like three years
Tokilan.
Where's your axe?
Oh my god, that's true.
Let me get my axe real quick.
Axe.png.
Let me get my axe, guys.
Is this a real PNG?
That's a real PNG.
It's always a game of am I downloading a real PNG or a fake
PNG?
Oh wait, this is not even... Oh my god, This is a, this is
a, wait, let me see, I can illegally, you want to illegally
download an axe, would you?
I would.
I would 100% illegally download an axe.
All right, give me a sec, guys.
I'm going to Majin Boo real quick.
Boo.
All right.
I'm just, like, really annoyed that I had to, like, redo all
my settings, too.
It's just annoying, in general.
Where's my axe?
Where do I put it?
Where the fuck did I put my axe?
I have a knife.
I found my knife, though.
My bloody knife.
I feel like that works as well.
Wait, actually.
Oh, shit.
No one's got the ball.
No one's have five.
Anyone's coming to try and colonize Norway?
I don't know if that works.
I don't know why to try to colonize Norway.
I feel it's going to be the other way around.
I found it.
I found my axe.
There you go.
Oh.
All right, I got it.
Boo.
Don't worry.
I'll chop the zero away.
Norway.
Ha.
England never called thy Scandinavia makes you think who's
these two
oh he's a he's the prince of Norway oh my god also I found
out you can't even the VV VIPs you can't even buy them you
actually have to be VVIP what's the point even with all that
money you'll never be seen as vvip you're new nouveau rich
not old money rich you're not
old money i literally just googled axpng guys i got what i
got
king leader thank you for the he has like the great gasp
king leader the super chat thank you thank you Hey, are you
secretly teo-dokie about a PNG look suspiciously someone
that was turned into a salsa earlier this week?
Oh, that's my that's my cousin rest in peace I'm Norwegian
dokie I'm I'm dokiland not dokiland
Battle axe PNG Alright, let's see if we can get battle axe
PNG I don't know you guys know this but it's very hard to
find PNG axes
all right maybe maybe this one will work
okay all right let me disappear for a sec I'll just dual
wield
oh wait England is carded up I forgot about that I forgot
England was too aggressive last time there we go We're the
best of both worlds.
Wealing for both hands.
Ha, the weak.
See, if you were Holland built, you can wield one each.
Where is Holland?
Oh, there he is.
He's just chilling.
It must be so easy.
Easy, like, so...
Not easy, but like, more chill being a striker than, like, D
and midfield.
Because you're just chilling up there.
You just got to do your job, you know?
Oh, so the passes have been, like, absolutely atrocious on
Norway's team.
I'm sorry.
He's saving his ult.
Yeah.
I feel like when you're a striker, you just exist up there.
Like, like, you look at Holland, go jogging his way over.
He's just like, not my job.
I shoot balls.
I don't do anything else.
Ball goes into goal.
Look at him.
He's just casually walking over.
He's like, not my job.
Okay, chat.
What do we call this, Doki for the archive?
Doki, Doki, Viking, duck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I wonder what team I'm cheering for.
I don't know.
It's hard to tell.
I know, right?
I have red and white on both Norway and England.
Yeah, it's so hard to tell.
Now let's just, hey, guys.
When ball go to me.
But ball when go to me, so me do job and be striker.
I just like watching this haul and just casually just
walking around the pitch.
Just being like, where is ball?
Why is ball not on my feet right now?
Where is the ball?
He's literally just casually just walking around.
When ball go to me.
Midfield, do your job.
I'm waiting for ball.
Oh, Sneed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Watch, though.
Hollywood immediately blame his support for no heels.
Thank you.
The super chat.
I think England has been very, Very aggressive.
Guys, this ain't looking too good.
I guess, like, I don't know.
I mean, I guess Norway's defense has been alright, but like.
Sorry, my Jolly Bees came.
So I just paused my train of thought.
But like, I'm getting a little worried, guys.
I'm getting a little worried.
It's okay, guys.
Norway's?
Norway's building all right now.
Oh, shit.
Oh, nice.
Nice block.
Quarter kids are always very nerve-wracking.
That was a good block.
Trust Holland?
Well, for that to work, Holland, they need to give ball to
Holland.
They need to give the ball to Holland first.
I think I saw Holland touch the ball one time.
And then he's like, man, too fast.
I wait now.
I was like, I just love watching, like, Holland POV where
he's just casually just walking around He's like, maybe I
should chase this man And he's like, too much work, I wait
Oh, Holland
No, Holland's so yeah, he's just Guys, he's just Guys, 65%
possession control That's not good That's what I'm saying I
feel like I've seen majority of Oh, that's a good head here
I've seen majority of goals go to Madrid ball position going
to England you're right he has to save his leg strength to
kick ball into goal
I like how he's the only one up there too like it's like
five England players up there on mid and then there's
Holland just the little red dot it's like a little pimple
oh England again England's scared because they don't want to
Well, they just need two more yellow cards And then they
have to take their players out Do you guys know Each yellow
and red card is like What $10,000 right?
Yeah, it's like 10k, right?
Yeah, because Getting yellow red card is not like
Decoration, you actually get fine You're like Yeah, red
cards are 20k And yellow cards are 10k I was like And And
let's just say Canada did not care
And Canada Then I was like I was like Like I was watching
the Columbia versus Swiss game And then like seeing all
these Swiss players get like yellow cards and stuff And I
was just like They don't care They have so much money in the
banks Who cares
That's just a penny for them All those offshore accounts.
It's like a super chat.
Is this game paying a win?
I mean, yeah, technically, if you have the money to get
yellow and red cards, technically, yeah.
I don't know why Canada was fucking getting so many yellow
red cards.
They thought it was hockey for a second.
Guys, the Canadian comp is not as good as you think, guys.
Guys, we're not playing grass hockey right now.
I don't even know if it's 10K US or 10K euros.
Because no matter what, our currency is not great.
Oh, yeah, shout out to Outlet.
Outlet drew these for me.
I asked Outlet if they could draw me.
like a holland ponytail and then they're like i can do you
even better and then i also got a hat new hat guys new hat
lots of foods here this game has been pretty boring i'll say
where are my aggression come on england what happened i saw
that mexico england game where the fuck was it i it's just
all passes I mean, to be fair, that's all football.
But, like, you know, cool passes.
Like, the one I saw from Colombia.
Actually, they would choose who to support as Mexican.
Do I support a team who knocked us up but showed us respect
after the game?
Or hate watch them and support Norway?
Well, Holland gave a shout-out to Mexico, so you know who to
support.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I like it was just Holland up there.
Always hate watch.
Watch.
Cool.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let me
score some fucking ghosts.
Oh my god.
Give me action.
You guys both colonized.
You're both colonizers.
We're at my action.
Oh, that was a, oh, that was actually a pretty good pass.
Oh!
And he was there when it Matt that actual fumble that would
have been a goal that actually could have been a goal and
Holland shows up when it matters wait how did he get there
how did how did wait a minute oh it wasn't Holland I thought
that was Holland never mind that was a guy would that was a
guy that was bald he teleported for some reason because like
you know how Holland has like really pale blonde hair so
sometimes it looks like he's bald you know because his
ponytail is so tight as well so then like and then when I
did a close-up I was like oh no that man is just bald that
man he's just bald it teleports behind you that was actually
really close goal too that would have that should have been
a goal but the the whoever that player was choked and and
disappointed his entire country today well i'm gonna get my
food is is that it's break time is it hydration break me brb
i get my food
i'm back just in time i had to get my i had to get my fork
they didn't give me a fork got my jolly bays sponsored by
smart water okay i will say this game is a little boring
i think it's also because it's really hot right it's really
hot right now in miami
this is why it's hard to pick games to watch because i have
to also like figure out if like like it's so hard to figure
out if a game it would be like really fun to watch or not
because it depends on the team's play style.
Because England was so aggressive in versus against Mexico.
But this one is like, I don't know.
They seem more passive.
Same with Norway.
They seem really passive right now.
Also, the heat must not be like great for them.
What's that in like non-freedom units?
What's the temperature?
Because you guys say 100 degrees.
And at that point, that's boiling.
Like no human should be surviving that.
They also can't be super aggressive because, well, England
can't be.
Norway can.
Norway doesn't care.
41?
Oh, shit.
Find his offshore bank account.
What the fuck did Norway do?
Like, he just stood there.
That's his fault for running into a wall.
That's his fault.
He has right away!
He was tying his shoe!
Bro, all of them are like sweating like crazy right now.
Oh, that is an insane...
That's a freak.
David Beckham, where is he?
Give me a close-up.
Where the fuck's David Beckham?
I want to see that.
but not David Beckham?
Where's the spice girl?
I always like during like free kicks slash penalty kicks.
Or like not free kicks.
When they build a wall, there's that one guy that's just
salmon flopping.
That's just they just have to be a fish.
I don't know why.
What's the...
Oh, I guess to block off, like, shots between legs.
Like, what's the point of that?
What...
Like, what's the point of, like, being a fish on the ground?
Is it to, like...
I know the wall, because I've done the wall.
Like, I built the wall before as a goalkeeper, because the
goalkeeper has to, like, control where the wall is
positioned.
But, like, what's the point of the fish?
The fish on the ground.
Is it to stop balls going between legs?
Ah...
people shoot under i see oh when the wall jumps yeah i
forgot about yeah the when the wall jumps and stuff so you
just smack his ass or some shit the ball hits the butt also
i just felt i know this is like i know you're like wow joki
i kindly didn't know that role but because like i played
most of the things i know about soccer is from when i played
soccer but like in in like high school middle school soccer
we don't have you know how like um i didn't realize this i
found this out uh during like the columbia uh the columbia
versus um swiss game i was wondering why the goalkeeper
doesn't just pick up the ball instead of like when they get
past the ball but like i you know i found out that it's
against the rule to for the goalkeeper to pick up balls that
were give that were oh that were like shot by your own
teammates oh they're rowing oh oh oh oh yeah but if you play
like if you play like um high school middle school soccer
like they're very lax with that rule because like i never
got called out for that but we also don't do the pussy
haramba shit
that's why they're always just i was like why don't you just
pick it up oh
He can walk!
Oh, I'm sorry.
The little posh boy heard Bruce's name.
Oh, does he want mommy to kiss your knee?
Good night?
Little posh boy thinks he's still in boarding school?
Never encountered what?
Never encountered real football?
Play your little games with your little boys.
the posh boys and boarding school and your little private
school.
They're fucking uniforms.
Oh, shit.
Where the ball go?
Don't be rude.
He's British.
That's why I'm not gonna like a twig.
The Viking made you cry, little boy.
I
need my spicy chicken
Joki's so toxic.
Welcome to football.
My eye is so close.
Oh, these passes are so trash.
I'm sorry, guys.
These passes are actually atrocious.
I'm not a fan of the passes that I'm watching right now.
They're so, I think it's like very sloppy.
They're very, on both sides too.
Both teams have really sloppy passes.
Especially for a quarter final.
Like.
I've seen better passes in group stages.
The heat must be really fucking bad or some shit.
You can see.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
You can see the heats getting to them.
Because this has been like really sloppy so far.
For a quarter final.
Oh!
I'm I knew I wasn't going to go in either.
But when he was positioned, I didn't tell him that he was
going to hit directly into the goalkeeper's hand.
Get out!
You're a...
No, you're not importing.
Oh!
Oh, offside.
Wait.
Is it?
And he's just like, I'm still hurt.
Let's go.
That was a good shot.
That was a fast shot.
That was actually an insane shot.
Oh.
That was such that was a good shot it happened so fast like
I couldn't it was like oh my the guy He didn't even he
didn't even fucking celebrate he was just like I'm broke
that man jumped higher than what oh my um he's just like I
gotta grab it I gotta jump now I gotta jump Oh that shot was
beautiful that was a beautiful shot holy shit oh my god
perfect geometry.
Holy shit.
Like that fucking pole traded.
He calculated the math in his head.
He saw the future.
The guy is still crying.
All right.
Oh, no.
You should have got up.
If you got up, you could have saved them.
If you got up, you could have been an extra player to Help
the team, pussy.
Look at that.
Play stupid games.
Win stupid prizes.
That's what you get.
Should have fucking got up.
Yeah, that's right.
What?
Oh my god, another one?
There's no way.
not their fault it's not their fault that norwegians are
just built different and you're just twigs it's not and
shouldn't have jumped that high that's on you shouldn't have
jumped that high that's on you the ball was you weren't even
you didn't even get the ball
that he was just giving you a little booster jump too he
gave you a little fucking little boost to help you get the
ball and that's how you repay him that's how you repay your
fellow
That was a foul.
No, he was giving him a little booster.
It's like in CS, you know?
In CS, we're like, you know, hey, boost me.
And then you climb on top of the guy.
And then to get an angle.
That's basically it, guys.
Oh, that's a foul.
That guy grabbed his shirt, bro.
Oh, you see how he didn't fall?
You see how that Norwegian didn't fucking fall after the man
grabbed his shirt?
That's real football.
That's a real football man.
That's a real man.
That's right.
Gordon, look at, that's a real man right there.
That's,
oh, it's too hot.
There's a lot of the English people in the stadium, though.
It's like mixed up red and white.
Norwegians are built different.
Why are you calling out Gord?
He knows why.
These are like, that's right, they're waking up.
The Norwegians are waking up.
They're going to, oh, the cool down's over.
that's right they realize miku's coming home
they see miku in the corner they know miku's coming home
guys five more minutes i feel like they'll add like three
minutes or some shit there wasn't a lot i mean there was a
couple of couple of fouls earlier oh my god sorry they got
confused he got confused he thought he was also wearing red
because he saw a little bit of red on the side
else to get from this game?
Yeah, Miku.
The caster was like, the caster was like, did he feel like
there's something to get from here?
It was like, of course, Hatsune Miku.
And for Mexico.
What record does Holland need to get beat anymore?
Anyway, I feel like Holland has broken every record so far
from the World Cup.
Is there any other record that he needs to break?
Most goals in the World Cup?
Where's he at right now?
He has seven.
What's the current record for it?
Come on, Holland!
Seven, one behind, messy, six behind the record.
Oh, all right.
Yeah, he's getting it.
Unless somehow, like, he just fucking scores 20 more goals
here.
He has broken one record.
The funniest soccer player.
guys don't worry in second half he'll activate his all
he's right there oh he slowed down he slowed down now
there's 20 people now there's all he got he got greedy he
was like I want another he got greedy why did you slow down
what the fuck there was like it was literally one guy and he
slowed that like pass the ball or score like it's that's
there's no why where's the third option come from where did
where did the fucking third option come from was pass or
shoot but yet suddenly he stopped he's like what if I
stopped though good save good save goalkeeper is good
who's oh wait that's him that's that guy that's the musician
that but i want to say i don't want to i want to say
boncho jagger yeah yeah mcchagger yeah yeah yeah that's who
i was trying to say that one Mick Jagger exactly exactly
what I wanted to say he's
got the moves like Jagger
what the fuck he was giving him a hug he's giving my Viking
hug they're both old guys you know when old people hit a
certain age they all sort of melt like you know when old
people get a certain age like and then like you just sort of
like all molded together he
thinks he's still back in boarding school
it's crazy we saw we saw like um oh that's a good pass
that's a really good pass oh oh i
can't even i can't even even say shit that was such a good
pass i i was like that that was such a good setup too i have
to say i can't even be mad at that that oh my fuck invited
the wookies the wookies are british yeah there we go david
beckham oh for one second i get to see david beckham's
handsome face for one second thing and i have to look at the
prince of norway for like an entire minute i
I can't believe Can you give me one second of David Beckham
They gave me Oh those are live Those look like wookie
costumes Like
It's that one guy's fault That didn't pass or shoot That was
his fault That would have been a 2-1 I can't even be mad I
can't even mad That was a good setup The pass The past?
That's how you do it!
Oh, he's so bad!
That's how you fuck...
I called it.
See, I was like, it had to be three to four minutes.
I called... I called it, guys.
Yeah, Sorlo...
That's how you fucking do it, Sorlo.
Take notes!
This is a team game.
Do you think the Vikings said...
Nah, Solo did.
They were a team!
check his bloodline check sore last bloodline and you know
i want to replay that shot though from england like the shot
might not be like super fancy but like the play was so good
i think the play was just perfect the cross the passes the
crosses and then like the shot it's just the whole play
itself was really good like that's why I'm being mad at that
goal.
I like, like, good setups.
Oh, my God.
Oh,
that was, oh, it got offside.
Offside.
Yeah, he was so lucky.
Like, like, I said, England setups are so, oh, like, look at
that setup.
If he did it offside, though.
Like, oh, my, like, look at that.
That was beautiful.
Holy shit.
That, oh, my.
If it wasn't, like, I mean, well, he didn't make the shot,
but, like, Oh, like, I don't think England is doing really
good plays right now.
Like, that's a good play.
Like, it doesn't have to be super fancy or anything.
As a team, the team plays crazy.
All right, so it's shorter up and Bellingham.
Yeah, how is this sandbagging?
So it can alt second half.
Yeah, the setups are...
You're so good.
I love the setups watching it.
Like, that's football.
Oh, stop the timer.
sorry don't worry we start at 45 anyway
um 45 45 there we go timers been stopped i mean it's getting
intense i will be sad if norway gets eliminated only because
like i just love the memes coming from there hasn't been any
great memes coming from the england matches but all the
norway matches have good memes i root for whichever team is
the most memeable
we know i can tell that my manager is watching a very a very
delayed broadcast
yeah oh yeah kane losing his voice was pretty funny i feel
like that's the only meme i can only meme i saw that that
was funny from england
king thank you the magenta super thank you thank you viking
toky apparently norwegians have the second most taco
consumption in world thanks to frid dagas taco taco friday
and the highest taco consumption in the eu if norwegian
loses are they going to turn you into salsa it's not my mom
i will have you know i'm three out of three watch lines so
um if they lose like I can't even save you like that's that
that's dumb it's we blame Miami we riot in Miami guys if
Norway lose we riot in Miami oh but so hot in Miami though
we riot in the Miami malls do the malls still exist in Miami
I was thinking oh but it's so hot we'll riot in the mall
There's air conditioning in the mall.
It's still the aircon riots.
Anyway, where there's air conditioning.
The riot on the beach.
Guys, beach party.
Beach party riot in Miami.
We can make a riot for us.
It'll be like spring break all over again.
Oh, yeah.
I'm so sad because I found out I lost.
You guys don't follow me on Twitter.
I was so sad.
I blame, I blame it on the Swiss.
Because I used a Swiss suitcase.
The Swiss card suitcase.
But I lost my, I have a luggage tag.
And it's like, I didn't realize that the fucking merch was
discontinued.
And it was only released one time.
One year in 2013 and it was um, it was from like this.
I bought this in Hong Kong a long time ago Um, and it was
like it's called zombie and it was like a Japanese like, uh,
like those like cute Japanese mascot brands or whatever.
I didn't realize that I thought they were really cute And I
didn't realize they only released merch one time In 2013 and
I bought luggage.
I bought like a bunch.
I remember I bought like memo pads and everything of like
don't know where the other stuff but the only one that like
remain a fixture in my life was the luggage tag and i've had
i've used it for 13 years so i bought it in 2013 and i've
been using that one luggage tag for 13 years and then today
um and then when i came home um i noticed it was gone when i
was like after the stream ended when i like my first stream
back home and i was like
Like during, because I know I remember I saw it.
I saw it when I grabbed my luggage at the airport.
Cause I was like, oh no, which bench?
Cause like the luggage tag was a little bit bent in half.
And I was like, oh no, which bench.
And then I was like, but then like I must have fell off
somewhere.
I didn't contact Uber.
Cause it was already like a cup.
It was already like,
um, really late.
Cause it was already like a day plus later.
So I was just like, uh,
so, oh my wow.
I was really sad when I found out.
Because I don't think you can buy it anywhere unless someone
sells, like, someone.
Because I looked at everywhere.
I looked at Makari.
I looked at Rakuten and everything.
Nobody was selling it.
Everybody was selling the memo pad, the plushies, the key
holder.
But no one was selling the luggage tag.
it wasn't even that expensive too for the resellers because
like the tag itself is like because the I guess like the
brand was not popular at all when they only released it once
it wasn't that but there it's so cute it's such a cute I
thought the I thought it was a really cute like mascot brand
and but it what apparently wasn't it didn't it wasn't
popular at all so like they were selling it stuff like the
memo pads the folders the plushies was like around like 10
10 to 20 dollars even though it's like 13 years old and like
it's a discontinued merch line
i mean at least that's like if anyone ends up reselling them
or something they've ever comes out with the internet at
least it'll be cheap i lost my fat baby mouse eating a
cheeseburger tag i got in hong kong recently too
And I'm just sad because there's a lot of sentimental value
because Tag's been with me through like everywhere like
everywhere I travel for 13 years and everything So that's
like what made me sad about it
The fat Mickey Mouse
Don't worry guys Holland is just He's like 99% of us all
guys Don't worry
He's just 99% guys He's charging his all Oh shit That's a
lot of ner What is that?
Oh Manchester Riz Thank you for the Akasu
Guys, guys, look Look, Holland is the Holland might be OP
But they have They take like They take like half time to
charge alt guys.
Did you remember the patch notes?
They nerfed his alt charge.
Yes.
Guys, he might be like an OP character.
But the devs nerfed his alt charge.
His alt charge is slower than all the other players in World
Cup.
One new team ups in Holland game season 9.
That's a rebalancing issue.
guys there's balance issues they hacked the nerve is all
many think it was super chat they could thank you and i'm
calling uber about the luggage chat i guess i left my phone
in one went by miracle they had it next morning i didn't i
just accepted it i thought it was just too late at that
point and it's also like a luggage tag too so it wasn't like
something super noticeable like a phone done with my jolly
bees i love jolly bees
gee that means i just have to make my own luggage tag that
just means next merch drop well not the next one next one's
my birthday merch birthday slash new outfit merch drop but
after that i'm gonna make a luggage tag so even if i lose it
at least i can replace it with my own
even if i lose it
I have lots of Doki luggage tags to replace it with.
Acer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
First you say you're Canadian, then you're Mexican, now
you're Holland.
Pick a side tomato, girl.
Also, hope you're enjoying the game, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Acer, thank you.
Thank you.
It was a little, the matches were a little snow first.
Also, I am wherever football takes me.
I go where football takes me, where I can find football but
uh oh yeah and holland is on an honorary mexican too um or
they say it but like yeah the first the first 15 minutes
first 20 minutes was boring as hell i will say but then it
started getting better in the last the last 10 minutes the
last last 15 minutes were intense i can be wherever football
takes me oh we're still in ads i'm gonna pee i'll be right
back guys
I'm back in time.
Suf, Arca, Saber, Medi, Byte, Papa, Solid, Miner, Rice, On,
Forward, Nexi, Allen, thank you for the super chat, thank
you, thank you.
All right, we're back, baby.
We're back for some more football.
Tyler's not playing the...
I want to say they're not playing the greatest, but I also
think it's just because...
He's not getting this.
He's not getting set up for anything.
You know?
He exists to shoot.
And like he can't shoot when he has no ball.
I think that's the biggest issue.
His existence relies on him having the ball in his hand.
But how can he do that when ball not in...
Well, not...
Sorry, not hand.
In his legs.
How can he do that when ball not on foot?
Where'd ball at?
How shoot when he no...
ball no ball no shoot sad sad holland
i got to use super chat thank you thank you uh jay lecone to
give a super chat thank you thank you thank you thank you
can explain holland and marvel arrivals terms i don't even
think i'm trying to think of what character he'd be in
like what tps character only a Exist when he has all what
DPS character is only useful when he's alting
Thor yeah, but Thor is like a tank and like like I feel like
Holland is a DPS
Yeah, but this Scarlet Witch is all there's also ask
Oh shit time All right give me the clock what's the clock at
oh i'm accurate as i'm not accurate i'm like one second
whatever it's fine it's just it's close enough
he's like no it's him no he fouled no he fouled that's some
good ass mics i can either him arguing i
always like seeing like his his other teammates are just
sprinting at the ball and he's just casually jogging he's
like don't worry ball come to me soon we're ball give me
ball oh another free kick can all you do is fall bro you're
getting too old for that shit I don't know how old he is bro
he was just giving you a he was just giving you a pat on the
back bro he saw you were choking and it was patting you on
the back you how
old is kane how fucking old is he 32 you're you're god bro
bro you can't keep falling bro you got your your bones ain't
gonna help you
who who why is he doing
Just a friendly pat, you know?
He saw you was choking, bro.
He was just helping.
Here's the little fish.
Here's the little fish on the ground.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, but that's a corner, though.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, wait.
He hit his own teammate.
He's like, he's like, fuck you for last Saturday, bro.
I know what you did last Saturday.
Fuck you, bro.
That was a Kory.
It was a gold kick.
Get friendly fire.
That, I...
Bro, you knew I liked that girl, bro.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that was a good...
What was that?
Oh, what was that?
Oh, did Alan fucking...
It was so long.
Like, did you guys see that?
He was like, so long.
He palisade him.
He's like, what happened?
Bro did a fucking fighting game move.
He was like wrestling, for real.
Okay, but that was on the British guy.
That was on the English guy's ball.
The guy was, like, grabbing on him while he's trying to get
the ball.
Bro got grappled.
Probably was like, me finally get ball.
and you what you doing almost threw him up it was like Paul
finally here why you do this why tiny man on me
and straight he's like why tiny man on me me cat ball
I wish they had a close-up of that exact moment.
That was so fucking funny.
Literally was like, get grappled.
Tiny man trying to get my ball.
Holland smash.
Holland throw.
You see, if Holland was playing, If that was a UK guy, if
that was an English guy that got grabbed like that, he would
have just fell down.
You know it.
You can't deny it.
That guy would have just fallen down, held on to his knees
and ankles, and started crying on the field.
See, a Norwegian fights back.
Holland here.
Holland!
Oh,
support!
Holland gave ball!
mistake playing for team.
Holland was like, we're a team.
We're a team in team game.
What was that?
Holland needs heels.
Where is the support?
Holland should have played for England.
Holland Holland only one man
where is team in team game should should holland play solo
holland go flake now team useless
that's like the that's like the the usual dps shit No
support I go flank
What the fuck What the Oh That was a nice try though That
was a nice try Holland first time with ball He's warming up
guys This is the first time I saw him Done anything with the
ball
He's just kidding Does this warm him up right now?
Is that?
Yeah, I was like, that looks like his dad.
I was going to say that looks like his dad.
Handball!
Oh!
That's unlucky.
How the fuck did that bomb manage to miss everyone?
Like, did it actually hit nobody?
Oh, it hit him.
Alright, it's another coroner.
Another coroner.
He's like, number one more.
He's stalking right now.
He's scoping it out.
God, it's so...
I can feel how hot it is.
Just look at this.
Let's go!
The hot is like, me, no score.
Oh, they're just casually walking over and it's like We
scored but not me
Oh, that was a good kick That was a good score That was a
good, that was a good one That was a good one I had to
figure out which one was how Which one was Norway Like I
used the last one And fall in that good Not me score Holy
shit What the fuck?
It's like, get up, baby!
He's a tough one.
It's a man.
It's a UFC bro.
Sign that man up.
That guy should be wrestling.
You can send him flying.
Maybe Hollis should play a defense.
Like, bro, get it out.
He tapped him.
I will beauty human move out of the way me play soccer me
play football oh no wait what oh because of this no way all
in doubt I'm just gonna see through
him not so far Not the fuck.
No fucking way.
He was too at, oh, leave me squirt.
He...
Aw.
Aw, Holland ulted too early.
He ulted too early.
He failed the barring step.
Damn.
You have pro-alted too early, pro-alted
and...
Oh, and wasted.
Oh, no.
Pro-alted and spawn, bro.
You-
I'm in angry.
Mis-input.
I'm fucking mis-input.
God sold the team fight.
It's not hot as fuck.
He thought he was Tani Pug.
Oh.
You can't replicate it.
Oh, wait.
It's...
It's Norway's throw, right?
It has to be.
There's no way that hit England last.
Doesn't that?
Him?
Is he okay?
Oh my god, look at him.
He's not, look at him.
He's not flopping.
He's just sitting down, casually sitting there.
It's like, don't worry, just a flesh wound.
I could, I can just give me like five seconds.
It's give me five.
Mr. A.
Holland.
Look at that.
See?
That's how you take a hit, England.
Look at him.
He's just like, it's okay, I'm all right.
Like, don't worry about me, I'm okay.
Yeah, they lost the goal because Holland got...
Holland got mad.
Even though it's thinking of the super chat, thank you.
I'll lock it off.
That's bad, though.
This guy's a really good defense.
He was really good at D.
What the?
fuck was that pass what the fuck
guys holland's getting antsy he's gonna push again if you
don't give him the ball guys please he's gonna push you
gotta give him the ball
he's gonna start smashing again he's gonna oh my
god that was scary that that was okay that was a little
scary maybe we'll get penalties ashley would love would love
to watch a penalty on stream it's less stressful watching
penalties live is so stressful but i think watching on
stream is like more fun
how's getting antsy he's getting antsy someone quick
I don't know, like we get another time, we get like one one
till like after um After the main set and then we get
penalties Like how they can only shoot one penalty At least
he can shoot up at least he can shoot a ball guys I feel
like that's the only way Holland can score
I think like at least because like they cannot pass to
Holland because Holland It literally has like five people on
his ass right now.
Yeah, he's like triple marked.
There's really no way to pass to Holland because everybody
else is just like on him.
And then he saw the fourth person.
He was like, get out!
Only three Max on Holland.
He's like, get in line!
Like look at that.
There's three guys on him.
right now
all right what
the fuck are these passes bro like at least come on these
are like baby passes you can't how do you miss those like
how are you making your your teammate run for your past
that's like next to you oh oh off side or byline
what even happened to him like did he sprain something
didn't say did
he like sprain something
look at that swollen feet somebody's looking at feet that
wouldn't have been my first thought Damn.
You instantly look down there?
Yeah.
You got set up.
I know what you are.
Feet is feet.
Not LeBron James's feet.
Trigger warning, do not Google LeBron James' feet.
Imagine that one couch meme, but it's Holland and the
English defendant.
Bro, can thank you for the super chat?
They can thank you.
Bro, why are they...
There must be Ericon there.
There must be like, why are you wearing a fucking suit, bro?
That shit is so hot.
Yeah, that has to be Norway's goal.
That bro is running into him like a goddamn car ready to eat
Sakai.
He's alive!
It's alright!
Handball!
That touched his hand!
Oh,
Molly, you think it was super chat?
Thank you, thank you.
Bro, I don't think anybody would have better feet than...
I think anyone could have better feet than LeBron James,
guys.
It's not...
It's like, basically, as a...
If you're a basketball player...
Also, that was a really close shot.
Apparently, like, people who played basketball for, like,
decades have really fucked up feet
because of the the shoes like clumping the feet it's like
basically like what buy it feels like foot binding yeah
that was a really good setup that should have been a goal
all
right now games are boring again Holland throw another
person on board throw
another guy
I demand another sacrifice on the field.
Mix it up.
Hoden demands another sacrifice.
Neem came up boring.
Holland, start ulting.
Eat him.
Just start eating the captain.
They won't notice he's gone.
There's no rules against it.
Just unhinge your jaw and swallow.
The Norwegian Miku demands another sacrifice.
Wait, hold up.
What did I miss?
Did Norway score a 2-1 not long ago?
Well, Holland ulted and spawned.
No, no.
Holland was trying to spawn camp one of their supports.
And then their support player, the support player's dad
works at FIFA.
And then cried about it and reported him.
So then Holland got...
Got suspended for one minute.
And the support player got his RP refunded.
Holland won ball.
Give Holland ball.
Holland made him miss input.
Yeah.
He like...
There were those who don't know why the point was refunded.
Holland decided all too early before the ball was kicked.
And then pushed the guy on the floor.
but it was very funny though it was pretty funny he's like
get off me beauty human the viking cheese kicked in he's
like i'll show you how to colonize
i like all that oh my god my algorithm is just all holland
right now i i don't know how this happen but my my algorithm
is just holland oh my wait look at this guys wait
can we run the airplanes in the night sky like shooting
stars i could really use a wish right now wish right now
wish right now you colonized america i colonized you
No way, I'll retweet it for you guys.
I retweeted it.
Also, here's the bonus.
This is unrelated to Holland.
Oh, pussy passing it back to the goalie because you can't
fucking defend well.
Fucking pussy.
Got skilled diffed.
Getting skilled diffed right there because you can't do your
fucking job.
So you get your little...
Mommy goalkeeper to fucking bail you out.
If he knows how to defend, he wouldn't have fucking ran back
to Mommy goalkeeper.
It's like, get out of jail free car.
Tactical reset.
See, this is different.
This was different, guys.
This was tactical.
What Norway did was tactical.
This is different.
This is just Haramba.
Look, Norway was Harambaaling.
Why are they Harambaaling?
I guess they want...
Oh, no!
Oh, it's okay.
It's alright.
Why are they Harambaaling?
They don't believe.
They aren't fucking stalling hard.
I don't know why they're stalling so hard.
Oh, that's not good.
This is not...
Oh, nice.
They're a bad pass.
pass.
Holland's right there!
Holland!
Oh my god, there's three people on Holland, though.
Oh, please just pass!
He's right there!
Doesn't matter, rule!
Oh yeah, yeah, thank you for a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, his sock is torn.
I feel bad.
I would be so frustrated,
have three people on holland three victims for holland sad
holland walking away when my when my turn when can holland
shoot oh holland's like me me me oh that was a nice pass
though if only he why are you not to holland for holland
Holland was like why are you not five feet tall if you were
taller you could get ball where
is your jump Holland set this up for you why are you not
seven feet tall like Holland
15 minutes left they have to they actually have to um
it's like no Holland do not not Holland Holland I'm watching
you Holland no push Holland no like I'm the ref was like
talking specifically to him too I'm watching you what the
was that oh oh my god no oh that's a corner kick right oh my
that was so close there were so many close calls i
need to see that replay oh my god what a save he's like get
out of katsi
Okay, never mind.
That was hitting.
I thought that was his hat, but that was just the goal post.
I was going to say, what a save, but still.
What a save from the post.
Guys, good job on England's post.
It looked like his hat for a second.
I thought that was his hat.
I was like, Jesus Christ, did he got that?
Post MVP.
Guys, don't worry.
He's going to ult in the last five minutes, guys.
Guys, they had the new patch notes gave him a slower alt
charge.
Instead of like, um, instead of 3,000 energy, it costs, it's
like 10,000.
So like the only time you could ever use a Holland ult is at
the last five minutes of the game, guys.
They, guys, they nerfed.
I know, I know.
They like nerfed him.
The patch notes just came out last day.
I don't know if you guys read the patch notes.
he currently has the slowest alt charge out of everybody
what am i supporting again i don't know
also i just think it's just really fucking hot right now in
miami so it's like a lot harder oh oh that was close holy
shit if he was if that player was just there like even one
second earlier why did he why did he bring a kid to a
football game legitimately if he was there one second
earlier that would have been insane that would have been
insane then they say a lot oh wait then like people say that
like sources were saying that norwegians team a lot of
people in norway right now are really sick at the moment
Are they better now?
Are they still sick?
I do feel like Norway's playing a little weaker, but in
England's playing a little stronger.
I think there's also that, too.
I was going to say, yeah, if you can afford a ticket to the
World Cup, you can get a babysitter for a baby.
Like, yeah, they're still recovering from what, like, the
flu or cold or something.
Because I think that's also why I think Norway is playing a
little weaker than usual.
Because this is like it's hot and they're sick as well.
Witch!
It's like a little like we're playing footsies right now.
What the fuck am I watching?
They're like playing hot potato.
Oh, hot potato.
Patty cake.
that's why.
Because this is like a weaker version of Norway, I feel
like.
Like the passes aren't the best.
And like, it's just sloppy.
It's just pretty sloppy from Norway.
I think England is playing a lot better.
But I do think Norway is playing sloppy as well.
I think like both can be.
Like it's just the factor of both of that.
Because England is playing a lot really good right now.
But like I said, like Norway is playing sloppy, too.
Oh, good D, good D.
Bro, there's like 20.
Are you sure there's 11 people on the field?
Like, guys, I need a head count.
I need a head count.
I think they sneaked in, like, five more players onto the
field.
I'm...
Yeah.
Guys, I think they sneak, like, all their substitutes and
the coach and some fans onto the field.
Guys, I need a head count right now.
There's too many people on the field.
Who's this guy?
Carlson is Norwegian?
I was like, wait, I didn't realize the...
The...
Ashtoy guy?
I thought...
I didn't realize he was Norwegian.
The butt plug guy?
The...
I feel like that's like, that's just like, I know he has a
lot of accolades and a lot of credentials and everything,
but everyone will always remember the butt, the butt plug
man, even though he even he wasn't even the one.
He wasn't even the one that was that topic was about, but he
made it pop.
He gave, he paid attention to it.
I know it's not even him.
that's like he didn't do it but he was the one that gave
attention to it so now everyone associates the butt the butt
plug thing to him oh so um in chess there was a guy that um
so was he was he playing against Carlson I don't remember
was he playing against Magnus
or was it who was he playing what was the guy playing
against in chess Okay, so basically, you face the guy, and
then, like, the guy beat him or something, right?
The guy beat Magnus, and if there was, like, cheating
allegations, and then, I don't know who brought it up, but
someone brought it up that, like, you can have a butt plug,
like, the guy had a butt plug that vibrated, like, moves for
him to use.
I think Carlos was like, it could work, you know?
It was like...
You didn't deny that it was a...
That it could be a viable strategy.
Yeah, with Morse code.
The butt plug Morse code going crazy.
Oh, I mean, yeah, like you just shot...
You just passed the ball to the goalie.
TLDR.
Carlos is a post.
and was accused of plug-pulling.
Thank you, Mr. Rich at Papa.
Thank you.
So that everyone associates the butt, but the butt plug,
like cheating scandal to Carlson, even though he wasn't even
the one that it was about.
But like, because he also brought attention to it.
I don't remember the other guy's name.
I just remember you, like, Carlson was there.
David!
Oh, goodbye, David.
I love Ben.
than like Beckham.
That was a, that's a good movie.
I think I watched, re-watched that movie like three times.
Oh, Holland hungry.
Give Holland ball.
Holland shall now start running.
This is the first time I saw Holland run, guys.
He hungry.
They need a Haran ball this for Norway.
Because this is getting, because I think England, England
has definitely had more possession.
of the ball versus norway they've also been like they've
been like they've they've been setting up better plays i
feel compared to norway norway does i haven't seen any like
strategic setups yet i've seen an amazing shot from norways
but like not like any strategic plays in terms of how
they're setting up plays for their players oh oh
it was right there it was set up Perfectly that man juked
the shit out of them too That was such a perfect setup and
he fucking choked That was insane That like look at that
juke like oh my god That I don't know who that guy was
number two that was beautiful that was an insane juke from
him Number seven sorry number seven like holy shit
yeah good defense but that was number seven whoever number
seven is I don't know who number seven is but like that shit
was beautiful that juke was so good
like that's really hard to do too like um
who's this
oh I think maybe plus five.
Or it's less than that.
No, actually less than that.
There's been less fouls.
Plus two or three.
I feel like...
I mean, there has been a lot of substitutions, though.
Luis Sores.
Saka seven?
Yeah, Saka.
Was there a hydration break?
Oh, I forgot there was a hydration break.
Oh, yeah, then it's five.
I wasn't counting the hydration break.
save.
Then it'll be like five then.
Yeah.
I legit forgot about it.
I blame the guy that didn't fucking pass.
Or shoot.
It was literally right there.
He fucking choked.
If he shot or passed, I think they would have got to, it
would have been two one.
Oh.
I will say i feel like other than holland fucking pushing
people um i feel like guys like oh oh oh holy shills oh my
god that would have been that would have been insane goal oh
my god what the fuck he almost didn't USA that was crazy
that's insane bro what the fuck was he doing plus seven
where the fuck did the seven minutes come from and there was
bit there was no fouls yeah grab him grab him show him how
colonization works Viking style
okay i i'm sorry guys i think i feel like holland has been
sort of non-existent in this game i don't know i feel like
he has like barely like i think it's just because like
england has marked him um england has like marked him so
hard that like he just exists yeah
he's just like is just there yeah i feel like nobody's like
nobody's like uh what's the word giving him opportunities
right now yeah he just needs like he literally needs like a
chance to all ball no go to holland holland no kick
fuck he's just like guys it's okay i'm okay guys it's okay i
just need a little stretch it's i mean if you want to give
him a yellow card i don't care i just it's all right i just
need a stretch guys i'm i'm a big boy yeah
he has a crap he's like stretching his foot
oh yeah i've done those types of stretches before i had to
help my strikers with those.
It was a 1960.
Is that AI?
Is that... Is that AI I'm looking at right now to zoom in on
AI?
Alright.
Ain't no way.
It's okay.
Game the clock.
You're so smart.
We're not smart.
They're just going to keep extending.
Oh, that's not good.
That's another.
That's another player down.
That's not good.
They lost another starter.
Norwegian players are dropping like flies right now.
Oh, oh.
No call.
We keep going.
See, he's not on the ground for 80 minutes.
Oh my god, this is getting way too tense now.
This is getting...
Oh, nice, nice.
Weekend.
That man has a weekend.
Let everybody know this man has weekend.
Oh my god.
The Crusaders are here.
They're ready to colonize Norway after the match ends in
Miami.
Forgotten King.
Foul, foul!
Red card!
$20,000!
They had $20,000 on the king!
Oh, I'm drinking bubble tea.
Oh, now that they have to...
They have to Haranbaugh this.
Oh, no.
That's...
Oh, oh, KKK!
He's right there!
Oh!
That's so... That's so scary to see.
Like, they have to...
They're trying really hard to, like, game the clock right
now.
So that has to be, yeah, that's England's ball, because that
was the goal kick.
Oh, that's Norway.
That's Norway's ball.
Norway's losing a lot of players, though, which is bad.
England hasn't had any actual injuries yet.
Oh, my God.
Look at that.
Look at, look at Norway's player.
He's like, I'm going to start doing stretches now.
And then the England player was like, I lost my leg.
is that bullshit bro the norwegian play was just like all
right i'm just gonna i want to do some stretches real quick
i'm gonna do some stretches and england's like my dad's dead
like what was that what was he fucking just grazed him are
you fucking getting me what was my family line just died and
he realized it he was like I forgot to turn off the stove at
home.
No!
The wind hit him.
Yeah, the air.
The air hit me.
Toki's dying and you're just laughing at him.
Dude ran.
Dude ran into the invisible 12th player of Norway.
No, I had an invisible 12th player standing in front of him
or some.
shit like what are you oh look now he's totally fine he
touched a norwegian he's allergic to norwegians guys a
mosquito hit him a true true a mosquito fucking ran into his
leg and it like cut off his circulation
Bro ran into air.
All right, 30 minutes of extra time.
The British PTSD hit him hard.
The strongest Brit versus weakest Norwegian.
Oh, well, it's break time.
Oh, yeah, I heard this.
I heard the live-action Moana film is asked, by the way.
Anyway, I just got that trailer on my broadcast.
I'm going to go pee real quick, guys.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Oh, shit.
I have to reset the clock.
What's the time now?
Uh, what would the time be?
It'll be.
Uh, what's one hour?
30?
seven eight now okay one hour and 30.
all right i'm back all right we're here
sorry i just had some work messages all right this is
getting intense now i didn't expect them to be like one one
oh penalties penalties the saddest way to go and i want a
team to go home sad
And the monkey paw curls, it's Norway.
We want penalties.
Just keep rowing, guys.
If you keep rowing.
Which side are we now?
We flipped it.
Okay, this is...
All right, left is Norway.
All right, I had to like...
I had to like re-evaluate which side was which.
The flipping gets me confused sometimes.
Holland was like, oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Me head wrong person.
This is second time me touch ball.
Wait, is this quarter?
I feel like it's a good equal distribution of fans.
I see red and white.
But then, like, Norway wears both red and white, though, so
I don't know.
I don't know, to be fair.
Same with...
I don't know if England wears red.
England wears red too.
Yeah, both teams were red and white.
So I can't tell.
Oh, that save was beautiful.
Oh, my God.
That was an insane tactical reset.
Oh, no.
No, no, no.
Okay, good.
Bad pass.
Nice, nice.
What a save.
Holy shit.
That was a crazy...
Oh, no!
Oh, no.
I...
Two, one.
Is that the Yaoi guy?
Is that...
Oh.
Holland man.
The monkey palm!
It's...
No!
Holland's...
Holland's work has been scored!
This thing is that...
That...
That was a beautiful save too.
That save was so...
Like he could... He almost got another...
Oh, if he was one second faster.
I asked for a penalty.
No, no, no!
I wanted a penalty!
That was such a good save.
I blame the witch!
She made them sick!
A witch!
Mr. McFluff and Kings, thank you, Miss Super Chat, thank
you, thank you.
This is Norway nerfed!
She nerfed them!
No!
My memes!
Please, Norway, you gotta score another one.
I need my memes.
It's not the same.
Football's not the same without the memes.
I need my brain rot.
Oh, that's true.
England versus France.
Wait, that is true.
I don't want British Meeku Norway, please.
Come on, you didn't terminate it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All they have to do is just stall it now.
They don't need to.
I mean, they could get three one.
Oh, we got the guy tripped on.
There was a guys.
There was a Norwegian mosquito on the field, guys.
Like I said, I think England is just playing up really,
really well.
have David Beckham and and Victoria Beckham guys you know
what at least I have David Beckham and
all the spice what spice was Victoria Beckham again
Beckham is timeless remember where you come from
Remember who your origins Posh by Santa No wonder she
fucking married Beckham I love the interview with I love the
interview with They did an interview with Victoria Beckham
And she was like Yeah I lived a hard life I lived a hard
life Yeah it was a struggle And then Beckham came in and was
like uh you were fucking rich girl like be honest come on be
honest like getting posh spice was like i lived a hard life
that was like that's a good one
what car did your dad drive in yeah yeah my dad had a push
he's like and and
Yeah, but she could have been richer.
All the other means you're cursing the teams.
You are the one.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Um, um, um, give me a sec.
Okay, Gabba.
Um, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not cursing anyone.
Give me a sec.
Um...
He got a foul?
Yay!
Bye!
Let's go!
Tip, chip, cheerio!
Ontario Ontario I don't concern
I've always believed in you As a fellow colony Of the
British Empire I would never betray Where I came from I was
I clicked Switch teams in TF2 Guys I got Guys, it's not my
fault.
I got auto-balanced.
Guys.
I got auto-balanced with them.
Oh, you're right.
I'm missing one thing.
Guys, it's not our fault.
Our bones.
Our bones are so weak.
Every time I cut.
I break a bone in my body every morning I wake up to 20
heart attacks.
What was that SpongeBob quote?
What was that SpongeBob quote, guys?
Tip, tip, cheerio.
A glass boy with glass bones and paper skin.
God saved the king!
Look at that!
On England!
Get that boy!
Oh yeah!
Oh, I forgot one more thing.
I forgot one more.
Oh, that's a fake PNG.
That's right, good save, my fellow Brits!
Good save, good save!
Sir, good sir.
What a save.
That is my football.
Is that football I'm watching, sir?
I forgot one more thing.
Whoa, how deep?
There we go.
Oh, good save!
Good save, Concer!
Marvelous save!
Oh, Very good save.
As a fellow country colonized by our king and queen, as a
British colony, I'm here to represent England.
Splendid, splendid football right there.
Wow.
I'm so like, I'm here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Yes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's my birthday.
It's like 20 minutes ago.
Just got back from seeing MRC and it would be top of my
night.
If I could get a happy birthday.
Thank you for everything you do.
Of course.
Happy birthday.
Yes.
So we had a great time there.
Have happy birthday to you.
God save the queen.
Happy birthday.
Day to you, God save the king.
Happy birthday, dear gals.
Happy birthday to you.
Good show.
Good show, everyone.
Goodness,
good heavens.
What a save.
Oh, good heavens.
Marvelous pass right there.
Marvelous.
Jolly Good Show.
Now that's football.
I sure do love a good football.
Cheerio.
See, I...
If England wins, I'm 4 out of 4.
Every team I cheer for wins.
My fellow Brits, who's down to go to the pub afterwards for
some good old...
For some good old beans.
For some beans.
For some bangers and mash.
We'll hit the pub after this.
At this turn of events.
Made me drop my monocle in disbelief.
Thank you for the super chat, Chris.
Thank you.
Want to go to the pub for a pint?
My fellow Brits.
jolly good show this is some jolly good football I'm
watching right now
quite a show chaps
it's alright it's alright it's alright you're already it's
alright
oh shit wait good say oh wait what so traitor and a lobster
back but I love your posh British accent Sydney thank you
for the super chat thank you Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Shoot some fucking girls, kid.
Come on.
Lead by example.
Oh, last 15 half.
15 minutes left.
No, I'm taking you with a super chat thing.
Someone get Scott Sterling.
Let's go, Scott Sterling.
Someone quick!
We need Scott Sterling!
We have 15 more minutes left.
But I should have paused the timer.
Oh shit, currently it's Mbappe Messi leading.
Oh shit!
Wait, both of England's strikers are on there.
That was so good.
That was a good goal.
Alright, what's the time now for the one hour?
15 minutes will be 45.
45 all right
what do you need some more teas chaps any more tea and
crumpets chaps
oh 105 plus four let me we're not I don't have a minute
counter right now I just have to do this by hand I only have
an hour clock oh
wait they're subbing Holland off oh We got them, boys.
We got them with the monkeys, my fellow British.
My fellow Brits.
That's right.
Watch your team lose.
Our king didn't even come and watch.
He doesn't even care.
Turn, go, go.
That's right.
None of the royal family is here to watch.
The custody battle is over.
Guys, guys, I got auto-balanced.
Guys, it's not my fault.
They auto-balanced me to the other team.
I got swapped to Redside.
I got swapped to Redside, and then I guess I turned British.
I was a British.
We all were a British colony, you know?
Guys, guys.
look by law guys our coins and money our coins have the king
slash queen elizabeth on it what can we do it's our currency
bro it's the commonwealth bro it's in the commonwealth law
from hong kong and canada we're british colonies what can i
do they all are balanced me
Oh, it's 105.
Whoops.
My clock is wrong.
Um.
All right.
Give me a sec.
Let me figure this out.
One for it.
Okay, I got this.
Watch this new clock.
Oh my gosh, someone quick.
They broke his ankle.
Guys, our bones are made of paper.
Vow!
Red card!
We all know our bones are made of paper.
The Norwegian did it on purpose.
Quick.
Someone call a doctor.
He was born with glass bones of paper.
skin every morning he breaks his legs and every afternoon he
breaks his arms at night he lies awake in agony until his
heart stops which puts him in his sleep red card in fact
three red cards one for each Norwegian for even daring to
breathe on him they breaks in his leg ref that Norwegian
breathed on him red Red card!
Damn.
He broke my bones and spit in my tea.
Red card!
He pushed us!
He tried to make us rejoin the European Union!
Red card!
Oh shit.
Oh my god, wait, oh, oh yeah, let's go!
Red card, the shot, the shot gave our goalkeeper a
concussion, red card, the air from the pass, from the shot,
blew down onto the, blew down onto our goalkeeper, and now
he has head trauma, red card.
It injured a bad red card.
It wasn't his turn to shoot, guys.
Nobody expects the British colonization.
Doki, even you cannot escape it.
It's leaving.
Thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, what the fuck was that shot?
That was just a pass.
Red card!
Oh, what a steal!
What?
The second save.
Hey, that goalkeeper is crazy.
Red card, the goalkeeper blocked the shot.
Red card.
Give that goalkeeper a red card.
I'm Terry.
Red card, the goalkeeper is doing his job too well.
Red card.
10 more minutes
what a fucking save holy shit
red card didn't let me colonize the goal red card
good show jolly good show what marvelous football we're
watching today my fellow commonwealth dragoons
Cheerio.
Guys, look.
As fellow Commonwealth countries.
England is the last remaining one left.
Just think about that.
What do you mean swap teams?
I've always been British.
For God and God.
country foul foul he grabbed my shirt i didn't ask and i
didn't give consent
the no the viking grabbed my shirt and it reminded me of the
time that the vikings uh invaded england and then it gave me
trauma and ptsd
Assault Eight minutes left They need a goal in eight minutes
I hope My dream is to have penalties But it's It's not I
don't know guys Not like the Argentina game Where they
scored four goals in 10 minutes
If only Maybe they'll start, just start, just start striking
the goal.
Start shooting.
What the fuck is that pass, bro?
Bro, what the fuck was that pass?
Red card, they're on the same field as us.
Look, I will say, the witch did curse Norway.
getting them all sick before the game so they're sick and
also the weather
ah good show good show
hey jude cover coming toky thank you super chat odin thank
you
yeah it was too far on the tip a red card they're wearing
red Six minutes left Red card Foul Foul
I had PTSD of Noro The Norwegian Vikings invading
I think anything that was cursed
During round of 16 Was in effect Oh my god this is so sloppy
from Norway I think Norway was playing very sloppy though
100%.
5 minutes left.
Oh my god, that's true.
Found it!
Red card!
Red card on Norway!
He existed in front of us!
Oh.
How is that a foul, ref?
Look, he's walking!
He's fucking walking.
Everyone knows you got to stay on the floor for 20 minutes
and then cry as if your dad just got shot in front of you.
Oh, this is Earl Gray.
Like a true British tomato.
That is so...
I don't know.
Yeah!
Red card!
Stay on the ground!
Stay on the ground for 50 more minutes.
Stay in there until Argentina shows up.
Yeah, as you guys can see, he was in the goalkeepers.
Yeah.
Red card the whole team He's ulting He ulting Red card
That's right Goalkeeper has right away Doesn't matter
Oh wait I got I got an extra thing too I got an extra thing
too Wait, I got something else as well, guys.
Oh, I got an extra thing.
Oh, my God, I can't pin it.
It's not good.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Yeah!
God saved the king!
Shout out to Outlet!
Outlet's on my side!
They're also cheering for it.
England.
That's right, Alan.
Show yourself.
You can't do that.
You can't do that face.
You were part of the problem.
Let's all, let all stream know.
Alan is also rooting for England.
Let all stream know.
That's right.
Yeah.
Oh.
Two minutes.
Three minutes left.
Three minutes left for Norway.
Oh, they're desperate.
Oh, bro.
What are these passes, Norway?
They're so desperate now.
They don't even care.
They just want... They're just shooting the shoot at this
point.
Two or three minutes left.
What do you mean?
I've always... What do you mean?
on England's side.
I'm a Commonwealth country.
Our coins have the king on it now.
I didn't even realize the queen was gone.
I thought Queen Elizabeth would be on our coins for the rest
of her life.
Post death.
What do you mean?
I'm English dokey.
I'm British dokey.
I've always been British dokey.
Oh no.
minute half left I miss the queen guys I miss her I miss
having her on my coins
they have to or all British is just playing clock they're
just playing the clock right now they're just stalling one
minute 40 seconds 45
it would be the craziest goal ever if they do it but these
passes though they're just gifting it to england like i i
don't know what the fuck they're doing they're literally
just gifting the ball to them with these passes like they
need like every opportunity they can and they're just
gifting it to them like what is that like bro
guys it's now final whistle Final whistle is coming.
Final whistle.
England to the semis.
Marvelous football, my fellow Commonwealth.
Four out of four guys.
Four out of four.
Every team I've chosen to cheer on.
Has won.
A perfect record.
It's coming home.
It quit.
Marvelous game, everybody.
Marvelous game.
Yeah, bro.
Miko is so pretty.
No more memes.
Okay, we still have...
Hey, whoa.
Him and his work?
Oh, whoa.
Milky, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jolly, good show, everybody.
Jolly, good show.
Why don't we head down to the pub later for a pint?
Why did they sub off Holland?
I don't understand.
Well, Mika was originally British because they took...
Miku was originally British, wasn't she?
Oh, wait, no!
Oh, the custody battle!
What was it?
It was like...
Japan, Brazil, Norway, and now it's...
Oh, the custody battle, yeah!
Miku has now swapped.
The British took her to the museum!
Tap a cheeky cup of tea!
I believe it They're gonna put her in a museum The custody
battle continues
Daddy, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Oh
my god, guys Maybe the curse was Miku all along Wait, you're
so right Maybe Maybe the curse With every team that
possesses Miku Falls in the next game The plot thickens
Miku is now She's like a cursed doll She was the witch all
along
Who is England face next?
It's whichever team It's whichever wins Argentina versus
Swiss Right?
Miku was the true witch all along guys She's like a cursed
doll
I was yeah France versus England I want the I want the
finals to be France versus England I think like I said I
okay Holland did all that game though it could have been two
it could have been two one if Holland didn't all all pregame
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you I feel like
I
got that too angry he got the 100 year war it continues that
was that was a good shot there yeah he pre-ulted
i think like i do think um that was a little sloppy it was a
bit sloppy from norway's end during that game um england was
playing a lot better like i think england is like
every game they're improving but also like norway was also
playing sort of nerfed yeah like i could tell like that that
was not how norway like the passes were so the passes were
like pretty bad like they kept missing like really easy
passes and then the players have to like run for the ball
versus like having the ball handed to them um and uh and
like I don't know, they choked a lot.
They choked a lot during, like, something.
Like, there was no setup.
I felt like, like, during the, like, the one game where,
like, one of them should have passed or shot, but then he,
he, like, choked.
He, like, hesitated.
And then they, like, don't set up any plays.
But, like, England was, like, setting up so many plays for,
like, for them to capitalize, uh, for shots and stuff.
Oh, yeah.
In 68 minutes, it's time for hate-watching.
Yeah, Sourloven made a really bad play there also um also I
think like uh also like the fact that like uh Norway had a
lot of players injured and stuff too I don't think England
subbed in anyone that got it like you know because you know
um look we're so weak our physiology wasn't meant to be
played weren't meant to play football but we wanted to play
anyway because we're passionate and like You know, when,
like, you see how the Norwegians are built, they're, like,
built like tanks.
Like, anybody's bones will break after slamming into them.
But all I'm saying is, like, even so, even when we're crying
on the floor, with how much it hurts, we still kept playing.
We didn't get subbed out.
I even when the 12th invisible Norwegian player Uh fucking
ran at us and made us trip and fall We still kept going Wait
That was such a funny foul When like I was like Wow how did
he like nothing touched him And he just fucking fell on the
floor as of his entire family He just got shot in front of
him.
I'll terminate it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
By the way, Doki, it's actually my birthday today.
Almost died with a heart attack this match.
But thanks for the stream, Doki.
Cover a wonderful hallway.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I hope you have a great birthday.
So maybe it was birthdays today.
Congratulations on being born and getting sped up by your
mom's.
But Jeannie, congratulations.
Happy birthday to you.
Birthday to you.
God save the king.
Happy birthday, dear Terminator.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Unless you're a, what is it called?
A surgery baby?
What's that word called?
Where they cut a hole out of your mom's stomach and then
because your head's too big.
for the whole?
Unless you're a C-section baby.
Yeah.
Because you're too fat.
You're fat, baby.
Yeah.
If you were a C-section baby, you were a fat baby.
You're...
Turkey, what are you talking about?
Dang.
Turkey, please.
All right, it's just a little British humor, you know, just
a little, just a little British humor.
Toki, did you pre-game?
It's just custom.
As per tradition, you pre-game every game.
Love, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Love how the king of England and therefore the king of cats.
Technically the King of Canada, dude.
Cougar Maras, thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's just some classic British dry humor.
More Dave, I get more David Beckham.
We all win.
You get Victoria Beckham.
I get David Beckham.
We all win today.
They're just, oh my God, the King of Canada.
The caster was like, I just don't see Switzerland ever
beating Argentina.
Damn Brett, fuck you, Switzerland.
Even the caster's were like, that's right.
Even dad agrees.
Yeah, we get all the Beckhams.
Oh, interview time.
How do you feel?
Yeah, we're watching Argentina versus Switzerland next
because I'm going to hate.
watch switzerland i just won switzerland the i just won
switzerland lose i don't care which country that swiss is
playing against i just don't i i'm not you guys if you're
from switzerland not you it's not you guys it's just it's
just switzerland knocked out all my favorite teams it's not
you it's your team
oh is he talk is that the norway coach or the british coach
he's mad
why is he so angry i legit thought it was a norway's coach
for a second because he sounded so angry oh he's brit it's
because he's british isn't he it's because oh is he oh he's
okay that makes more sense he's german okay that's like an
angrier british guy
That's just a, that's just a times 10, times 10, angrier
British man.
He can't help it.
He's just like, we won, but we play like absolute shit.
Fuck my team.
Bro, fuck all of them.
We won, but my team fucking sucked.
Like, what the fuck?
I literally thought he was a Norway's girl.
coach up for a second.
Yeah, like when Hilly was saying, he was just like talking
shit about his own team and legitimately thought he was
Norway's coach.
Like, bro, you just won.
And he's like, no, fuck my team.
They play, they play like absolute garbage.
Fucking trash.
And shit.
Doesn't matter.
We won.
It was fucking piss poor football.
They're like, whoa.
Whoa.
You sure you're not Norway coach like me on rivals we yeah
baby
he's like gray fox now wow it's like George
Clooney and thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
I didn't catch you after constant stream I want to say it
was awesome great singing great band great venue great
atmosphere and that night red balloons was piercing also I
did buy it yay thank you for buying a dog show I really
appreciate it That was the best part in your entire super
chat that you bought a dog shirt.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad you enjoyed the concert.
Wow.
Guys, guys, I'm, I'm four out of four guys.
Oh my god.
It's Holland's work husband.
You're like work wife.
So technically it's like Holland's
it the last holland me we get was when he altered he's only
gonna get better though holland like he's still like he's
like i feel like he's just gonna keep getting better and
better until he's like i guess like 40 i guess because
that's where like usually people retire but like he's still
pretty young like holland this is like his first world cup
too in a way so i feel like i feel like another four years.
He's just like he's just gonna get like better and better.
Yeah, yeah.
He has a lot of World Cups under him.
He has a two game cooldown.
Oh, yeah, sorry.
There was a patch note.
There was a patch note that shadow dropped right before this
game and they actually made it so that his cooldown was now
two games.
He has to, this, this, this was supposed to be his recharge
cooldown.
What a game, though.
I will say the beginning was so boring.
The beginning was a really boring game.
Like, at first.
But they didn't, like, I don't know.
And then England started picking up the slack.
Like, they started setting up some crazy plays and
everything.
And that was super exciting to watch.
Norway's two goals were really good.
And Holland pushing that guy, like, pushing two people was
really funny.
Oh.
Oh my God, he's his boyfriend.
Holland's boyfriend.
Yeah, England had, like, a huge possession.
on the ball like it was like what 60 at one point
and he didn't want to make his boyfriend sad he's like it's
okay baby i'll give you this one it's like don't cry baby
i'll push him is that what i'm gonna push him
big thank you the super chat thank you thank you How I just
didn't want to make Drew sad, that's all.
It's so wholesome.
He's like, your coach hated you.
What did you think?
Hey, no, no.
Is this his first World Cup?
It is?
Oh, he's made it so...
Oh my god, they are.
They are like boyfriends.
They're both their first world cup
That's cute I see it now guys guys.
I see it the mask calls for me that But for you in four
years the mask calls for me in four years Is that a heated
rivalry I see I Wait the cam oh my god holy shit what i
didn't realize it hit the cam wait a minute that's
crazy i didn't even notice it was going so fast that should
not have actually should not have counted what the wait
that's actually rigged Yeah, that actually should not have
counted.
Good show, everybody.
Good show.
Good aim.
Yeah, that would have been like...
That should have been like...
That would have been Norway's game if they didn't hit the
fucking camera.
That's actually insane.
Oh, the casters are saying they should have known.
Oh, my God.
Casters are hinting corruption right now.
They're hinting at that it's rigged.
They're like, wow, I wonder why it didn't flicker.
And they're like, because you're not, for those who aren't
watching the Canadian casting, they were like, wow, I mean,
they should be calling it out.
Like, it's very obvious when the ball hits the camera.
Like, everyone can see it.
And then, but then they're like, yeah, but I guess it just
didn't flicker.
Yeah, I guess it just didn't flicker.
Hmm.
you're like everyone knows everyone knows when it hits the
camera like it's not like it's not like something that you
can hide and oh that's crazy that's like crazy the casters
were like there's there was i guess there's just no flicker
i guess there wasn't
that's insane i didn't even noticed that too what
which goal was that was that the was that was that what goal
was that was that the first shot or the or the second shot
let me see if twitter has the um obviously i can't show you
um maybe i could give you guys a screenshot let me see on
twitter oh wait but guess what i saw though i got this gift
this one was a good one
was that the first goal oh people took ah there was a clip
of it uh but people took the clip down
i love the fucking salongie bousey
yeah i also were like that was i think the first half was
really boring the second half it got better
Oh my god, everybody is so mad at Sorloff.
Before I've been talking shit about Sorloff right now.
Oh my god.
Because you can see Holland just standing there.
Bro, I'm looking at all the clips.
And then you can literally see Holland was just standing
there.
It's like, ball?
Oh, where is Bob?
Where is Bob?
Oh, here it is.
I wish there was a better clip of it.
Let me see if I can find a better instance of the camera
hitting it.
Maybe I'll put a screenshot.
I don't think I'll get...
Okay.
I'll give you guys a screenshot from this.
So they have like a slow replay.
So it was apparently here.
So you can see there was an archway here.
Right here.
Yeah.
So like, apparently, if you hit that, you have to stop the
game.
But like, and they were like, saying how like everyone saw
it.
So this white line is like where the trajectory and it just
suddenly went down, straight down.
So people were saying that the casters were saying that like
it was very obvious and that like normally like everyone saw
it.
Everybody saw this.
You should, it should be called, it should be called a stop.
But then for some reason for this one, it wasn't disallowed.
Yeah, and then like everyone was calling for a stop, but the
ref didn't call for it.
Yeah, and they're saying that like, they're like, oh, it
didn't trigger the sensor.
But then people were like, that, it literally went down.
It went down.
Like, what do you mean it didn't trigger the sensor?
The ball went straight down after hitting it.
So like, there's no way it didn't trigger anything.
That's why people are calling it like rigged right now.
Yeah, the cam of God.
God wanted England to win.
That's why they always say for God and for God and the king.
God saved the king.
That's why they always say that.
That's rigged.
Rigged God was on England's side.
Yeah.
So like this was like, this was the point.
Black thing over here is the censor.
It's their king and country.
God save the king.
God.
It's their king and country.
Yeah, so this is where they circled it.
And it's like, they were saying that, yeah, there's no way
that the casters were like in disbelief.
Like the Canadian casters were like, what the fuck?
Why did it not get detected?
That's interesting, though.
That's interesting.
I didn't even realize.
I didn't notice that, like, that was the reason why the goal
was disallowed.
I mean, sorry, not because, like, not this allowed.
I didn't realize that was the reason why, uh, why, like, why
they got the goal in the first place.
I got everybody.
Oh, my God.
England right now bro I got the I got the World Cup
algorithm now oh my god FIFA says there was no peak on the
tracking graph suggesting the ball never hit the camera
cable in a build-up to England's goal Norway strongly
disagrees with replays appearing to support their case under
the laws of the game play straight up in all soccer twitters
mad mad damn all wait I like this I like this tweet all this
talk about 6 foot 5 Viking Holland and then a twink does
this yeah now if everyone was looking at replays and it was
very obvious that the ball hit it
that's crazy I still think my favorite I think my favorite
is just Holland doing so long, Gay Bowsy.
So long, Gay Bowsy.
That was crazy.
All right, guys.
I have, like, a couple of minutes before the next game, so
I'm going to call it here.
I'll see you guys in the next watch-along in, like, in,
like, 15, 40 minutes, actually.
As always, everybody, actually, no, 40, no, actually less
than that.
Maybe, like, 30 minutes so we can, at least, ah, 35 minutes,
so we can actually...
see a bit of the like be there before the kickoff hey guys
as always everybody say hi i'm ready to pause check you out
and move around to get that blood flowing and you say it for
me um you say it for the next game i'll see you guys next
time everybody all right guys bye tip tip cheerio